[Music]
and we return for more coverage of the
fide corporate chess championship sam we
had an exciting first round
you and i were talking during the break
there many great games right
absolutely uh there are so many games we
were kind of plowing through chess.com
events trying to find
some real gems to show you and there are
a lot there's just so many games being
played
in this event of course there are going
to be some gems
and of course it's going to be really
hard to find all of them in the moment
but we're looking forward to kind of
diving into some some exciting moments
right now
and well there's no better person's
chance to dive into than magnus
carlson's have this game up
and ready for our viewers you are
excited about this one because start
with a king's gambit
where white on the second move puts the
pawn f4 so sam
you take the wheel i mean this game was
fascinating what indeed in this knight
c6 move you were starting to talk to me
about some of the complications
absolutely the king's gambit
is a cygnus that i have suffered from
for a long time i really enjoy playing
it as white
partially just because it's the king's
gambit it's like the most romantic
opening you can play and i know magnus
carlsen has played it at the top level
before at least in i think like the
norway blitz chess tournament
um so i've had to look at his games
because uh everyone else who's defending
against my king's gambit
is um here he's playing it obviously
against
uh an opponent who he out rates
significantly who's rated like 1400
and i love that right he's giving his
opponent an experience
he knows he's probably going to win the
game i mean
probably being 99.99
nine percent certainty but he's he's
here
to play like the opera game he's here to
play
romantic chess and to go in for a
slugfest against his opponent and i love
that i think that's the spirit you want
from the world champion in an event like
this and the knight c6 line
is is interesting here uh here
after knight c6 uh if we can advance in
this position
after the capture on e5 in just a moment
there is d6 but black has knight takes
e5
in this position and white is still
better
but this can get really complicated
because white can take on e5 here
and then black has queen h4 check and
the move that you would
never ever in a million years want to
play is
king up to e2 which we should put on the
board
when queen takes e4 is checkmate so
you're not going to get that against
magnus carlsen
but it's fun to see that check made on
the board so
instead black has to play g3 after the
check on h4
and then after queen takes on e4 check
the rook on h1 is dropping
after queen e2 and queen takes h1
and then white wins the rook on h8 with
knight g6
check and then knight takes h8 which is
just
insane the computer is like maybe
white's better
maybe this is just insane i don't know
of course playing in this fashion
against the world champion would be
really incredible not impossible because
it is kind of a theoretical line and if
you've
kind of looked at this idea with knight
c6 you know you might know this as a
1400 player of course this didn't happen
but
that's uh that's why we love the kings
gambit that's why we love seeing world
champion carlson
playing the kings gambit because of
these kinds of ideas
and lines and i'm sure that magnus would
also have loved to kind of
see this on the board and have this kind
of rich uh position against his opponent
for sure and you know at this point do
not capture an e5 it's a hard move to
play if you don't know it's a night
sacrifice right it looks like you're
just
making a blunder but there's this h4
score whenever you
see an f pawn missing in the opening you
think about that check on the king
and so that's why knight 65 was playable
but instead
salmon we saw d6 and magnus took over
the center with d4 and once you
establish this pawn center and you don't
lose a pump in fact
win upon right it was kind of
overwhelming at this point and you know
the player did his best to try to hold
them off but you see
look at this well-established center
here and one of those pawns is
an extra one right not a lot of chances
to come back against the world champion
from this point on
but you've got to play the world
champion i mean that is
literally a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity
um so i think that all of us here in the
chat can be jealous here of santosh
you know he got to go in he got to play
the world champion and that's fantastic
and i'm just playing through the move so
we can just see the game and that was
pretty much the final stars after queen
c5
this bishop is under attack and the
bishop would probably have to
take this knight in f3 and said the
knight was dropped back to e7 and
down goes the bishops and now you're
down two pawns and a piece and magnus
finishes in style
he brings his knight out for the
checkmating attack
on h7 h6 is played stopping that but
look knight takes up f7 removing
the guard this knight on g6 is only
defended once it's attacked
twice but this 9 g5 is also threatened
so knight takes f7
a really nice way to finish this game
queen h7 made the king is boxed in so
magnus carlsen wins
the opening could have been quite
electric but still i would say a nice
fight from uh you know a player who saw
an opponent with double
the rating double the rating to say the
least of course
i think once you hear once you hear the
title world chess champion and of course
every player in this event at every
level knows who magnus carlson is
like you're not counting the rating
anymore you're just like oh my god i'm
getting to play
world champion magnus carlson um so
we've got a lot more games and some that
were
obviously a little closer so there were
some mismatches in round one as happens
and basically every tournament and
certainly a big tournament like this
but there were still some you know title
verse titled match ups and some really
beautiful games
yeah i'm pulling this one up here by
pragnanda who is one of the
biggest talents the brightest talents
that the world has right now from india
and he's playing venombush who is an
international master from belgium and in
this position
the i am with the black pieces venom
bush has a better position you see the
evaluation bar here
and the move to play was queen to h6
which gives up control of the f file
that looks not great but it saves the
king
because after queen e8 rook f7 in comes
an attack and unfortunately for black he
saw nothing better than to give up the
queen and that's a queen for just the
rook you see the eval bar
shoot up but instead there was one last
defensive effort
sam and it was this move knight h6
stopping checkmate right stopping
checkmate
the knight is hanging for free but that
queen needs to stay defending this rook
on f7 so the queen
can't just take the knight instead you
throw on the move rook takes bishop
queen takes rook and then you take the
knight and white's position
still looks very promising to me but
it's a complicated one it's a rook
for a couple minor pieces black has an
extra pawn in the start and this a4 pawn
is hanging so at least it would have
been a fight
and that was the one last effort that
ben bush could have
played to stay in this game that's
really really beautiful i saw the eval
saying that it was still
balanced and i was like how can you
defend like h6 queen g6 looks
over knight h6 is a really beautiful
defensive effort and of course queen h6
before that is also really instructive
as an idea we saw in the game between
uh anish geary and nihal saarin
had white and was pressing sarin you
know appear
with uh ramesh babu pregnant here
um aneesh went queen g5 right as
uh sarin went for pawn to h5
and this is a very similar idea you know
you're
under pressure that rook on f3 is
obviously taking up a threatening stance
and you've got to go for the queen trade
and anish did
and he managed to draw against his tough
young opponent and unfortunately in this
case
tebow did not and his opponent got the
better of him in this game
yes so it was a win here
uh for white because of this missed
opportunity but it was a true fight in
time
trouble can do some bad things to your
chest and it wasn't enough time
remaining i guess for ben wish to
fend off this attack and sam i pulled up
a game between some of our low-rated
contestants because i saw a really nice
checkmate and here
in this position we have ashish gupta
with the white pieces taking
armana the rudova and i was looking just
going through the games
and i said this is a really nice finish
because white is up
a couple pieces here and the queen on h5
is in a menacing stance but sometimes
you have to be deliberate
other times if you're slow black can
fend off the checkmating attack
so the great move seeing that you want
to land your queen on h7
and you have a bishop on d3 the move
play was knight f6
check getting rid of the knight's block
of this bishop so then after the
queen takes or whatever happens kha was
played queen takes h7's checkmate no
matter what so i thought that was a nice
little tactic to show
very very classic of course many of us
will have fallen victim to such a tactic
or
hopefully been on the winning side in
many many cases
extremely traditional here to kind of
set up this battery against h7 and then
to need the discovery
to get the bishop in the game right here
very sharp right of course from the
white player
for sure and so i'm gonna let you take
the wheel the next game that we prepared
because you were
really excited when we were uh trying to
find games you said this brighadzi game
that was the one that caught your
attention
so let's go to that one because i have
the moment pulled up here white
seems to be completely winning i mean
the engine says
plus almost 10 and there was a
really wild sequence here so let why
don't you take the wheel and explain
what happened
so first off i should mention that
regatta i think is
board one for one of the top teams here
and i want to say group
d forgive me if i'm wrong about that
group uh and
uh i think that's paypal hungry we were
mentioning earlier that they're one of
the favorites
in this game here he played the move
knight to d6
which is just thrilling because he is
sacrificing the queen
with check and sacrificing the pawn on
f2 with check
so after knight d6 we get bishop takes
c2
king takes c2 and queen takes f2 and the
king steps out now
and now there's huge pressure against
the bishop on g7
and ideas of mating with the combination
of the rooks on the g
file and the knight getting included as
well knight is coming to e4
maybe a knight coming into f6 and
there's like arabian mates and all these
things
but you guys also see the eval bar and
that there's
actually a defense here and the only
defense is
knight h7 which i think is just a
brilliant defensive move like two
exclamation points
you give up the bishop here on g7 and
the idea
is knight g5 splitting the rooks
and black is actually winning here
because the work on g1 is under attack
and the rook on g7
is now under attack and white's
attacking coordination has been broken
very very beautifully now in the game
black didn't find this amazing idea of
knight h7 knight g5
and instead uh white actually went on to
win the game
very beautifully yes queen dropped back
to defend
94 attack as you said queen comes back
and look at these knights just
on the light squares piling up on this
bishop on g7
and it was a checkmate in just a few
moves at the rookie seven
knight takes h6 and this is kind of a
sad thing to see you're up a
a queen for a rook and a knight and yet
you can't stop that knight f7 track
it's a beautiful beautiful position uh
for the white pieces right here
seriously that queen sacrifice is
something that i wouldn't even
considered
and sometimes it doesn't work out we saw
the evaluation part black should have
been ahead
but just to have that creativity and i'm
gonna go back to that position once more
to play a move
like knight to d6 in this position it
may not be necessary white was winning
but i always praise that kind of
creativity because you will win
games like this with knight 56 you also
i guess can lose a game you know
based on a miscalculation but ultimately
just to have that in your mind to sack
your queen with check
what a wonderful tactical sequence i
mean
as you say i would never have considered
it i mean knight d6
maybe i could consider sacri my queen
with check but then to realize also that
black is going to have queen takes f2
with check getting out of the kind of
tempo on the queen on f7
you know this is where my calculation
stops and i go okay
new line i need something different so
this is just incredibly creative and i
think that
this beautiful resource of knight h7
knight g5 the only saving resource for
black the fact that this exists
does not for me diminish the creativity
from bragazza here
and uh beautiful idea beautiful play
beautiful final position
i agree completely because knight hsn is
such a difficult to play the bishop's
under attack
and so your first artist let me defend
that square rather than blockade
on the file so i'm i'm with you knight
d6 was a phenomenal shot it
ended up winning the game for bergazzi i
did look for morgan stanley hungary
top board that team is uh certainly one
to look out for
okay thank you for the correction oh no
it wasn't meant as a correct just you
know
we uh there's a lot to cover we know
there's so many different teams uh and
brigadze
he's uh played in the united states for
quite a while strong international
master
and looking to lead the team to a world
championship title
so uh you also found this game sam this
uh
knight i don't wanna run the move i
almost heard the move i should not say
but the abbas of game against zawadska
so before i
ruin the tactical sequence i'll let you
take this over because black play queen
d6
and it looks like you're pretty close to
keeping things together for now
but we also see that engine says almost
plus
seven so what about this position sam
what was the crazy tactical sequence
so here we have grand master abbasov
with the white pieces and his opponent
zawadska i think is a women's
international master so we've got two
title players going at it here
another strong first round pairing and
in this position
the crushing move is knight takes b7
which abbas have found
and you're just undermining the defense
of the pawn on a6
so the key here is that even after the
recapture on v7
yes you are defending the a6 pawn still
you've got the king and you've got the
queen but white also has
another shot in this position with rook
takes c5
and the queen can no longer defend a6
and c5
and after queen takes c5 you have the
beautiful i think it's swallowtail mate
since it's on the kind of diagonals as
opposed to an epaulette
mate on the ranks and the files so
really beautiful mate right here
with the black pieces the rook and the
pawn covering those escape squares
in the game black did not take on c5 of
course
at this point when you've gained your
material back plus a pawn and you've
broken the king's defenses for black
there's not really a lot of hope
the final position was really beautiful
as white
mobilized his rooks and then set up a
battery with his bishop on e3
and in this position black resigned rook
takes c7 double checking mate is a
threat
and there are probably like 30 more
threats as well
and there's just nothing you can do of
course yeah one of those
sad positions so that's would be double
check and check mate
no defense left for black so really nice
tactical sequence there
and i actually pulled up one more game
to look at here and is the win by
maria muzichuk who is one of the two
music sisters very strong players grand
masters
from ukraine and look at this final
position she was playing a feed a master
this is a strong opponent of hers
but i mean this checkmate on the board
black's pieces haven't left
the first or second rank except those
two three pawns over there
oh brutal uh finish and i'm just gonna
go back a couple moves
to show how this happened because it
started out
even before here where things got out of
hand quickly
look at black's first move sam
g5 oh
that's that's concerning i
i would want to be like that's a mouse
slip and they meant g6
actually given that they're a feed a
master and that they're playing a grand
master
is that the most likely interpretation
here like i don't think that you go into
a team tournament
as a title player playing a higher rated
title player and you do g5
if i was a teammate and that's not a
mouse slip i'm going to be a bit heated
to be entirely
yeah i mean it's going to be a tough
pairing regardless maria music such a
strong player
a grand master opponent but g5 in a team
event because look at how quickly
she takes advantage a strong center
attacking this pawn
and the next move was g4
so it's not playing in fundamental
principle style and she very quickly
took advantage notice as she could have
taken this pawn she didn't she
prioritized development
and she actually made the move pawn h3
just trying to say
i'm going to take back with my knight my
queen if it took on g4 at this pawn on
d4 would have been captured so let me
just continue my normal development
and look white is three minor pieces out
the rook is an attacking piece and
black's only developed
one piece and has some long-term
problems this is an
amazing example of what not to do is
black
and what to do is white so instructive
uh wow g5 g4
that is just all in that is
that is um more insane than
like sardoche vs myth that's more insane
than you know
kevin borty playing the grab against
magnus carlsen
you know there's something to say for
the grub maybe
it's probably still the objective first
uh worst first move for
the white player but to play it with the
black pieces
that's uh that's insane yeah just to
finish this game
i really like this bishop b5 because you
do not want to trade queens as you're on
the offensive
and you're also threatening to win a
piece because bishop takes c6
wins a piece i'll show you why had black
played a6 for example bishop takes
the queen just lost its defender so this
queen is now threatened you can't
capture the bishop
and if you take the queen then the
bishop comes back and saves itself so it
took a knight
and then takes the queen white is up
that's
very very common in puzzle rush people
have seen this kind of capture and
recapture tactic many many times
and of course in this case there's
actually a choice because you could also
take with the knight and then fork on c7
i think that there's going to be a lot
of choice for white in this game
uh from this point forward yes and look
at this queen h5 check
in comes the bishop of c4 there's a
checkmate in f7 so knight e5 played
and just simple move bishop b3 the
mating attack's going to happen
look at these light squares that maria
took advantage of
just traded off now there's a bishop
planted here black hasn't developed the
king side the kings on f8
and just to show how the game concluded
f4 g4
i'm not going to give you my pawn your
queen stuck and no pieces can move
for black it's one of the saddest
positions you can see a knight c7 played
hitting the rook and very importantly
the e6 square you take you get forked
and queen h5 there's not really many
moves queen g6
would be a way to block the checkmate
but unfortunately for
black your rook is left under attack and
that's that
fantastic play for maria i feel like she
must have been enjoying her position
just so much you know around the point
that she's playing g4
and you just control the light squares
and everything in the position
and you know tons of respect to
the opponent uh for playing in this
event for head uh
heading up board one for their team
against tough opponents
but g5 g4 i don't know about that in a
team event i think that
whoever the team captain is needs to
have a little bit of a conversation
uh with the player about those
particular moves
well if i'm not mistaken the last name
of means wolf
and well that was a howler so
sam you and i we're gonna take a quick
break when we return
we will be ready for the second round of
the fide
corporate world chess championship
[Music]
and we are back we are getting ready for
some really exciting matchups
sam some of his teams probably gonna get
a little bit nervous it's only round two
but there's a lot to play for
already the matches are really heated
with
grand master versus grand master
matchups here
in uh group c we have magnus carlson
taking on anton korabob a tremendous
player
two very very strong players obviously
with the world champion there
so we're going to be focusing a lot on
that particular game but there are many
many
exciting games to follow in this
particular round already in
in round two we've got so many rounds
still to go
and korobov is i mean 2700 plus players
so that's a
very tough matchup for magnus carlson
that's reminding everybody of the
some of the standings here from the
various pools because we have different
divisions and as you can see in front of
you that uh
the leaderboards here we won't read out
every single name but that team from
morgan stanley hungary
in the uh group c there they're really
strong we saw burgazzi's win
in the first round and we see downstairs
they're also optivare that's going to be
a good one in tata we got to mention
them because they host
the tournament in vikings a the tata
steel company it's a
great one and how about from here uh sam
of course we have paypal
in group d from bulgaria but what other
teams stick out to you
i'll i think all the teams at this at
the top are really impressive i would
also mention this
tata consultancy services in chennai you
already mentioned tata
but they're a very very strong team they
have pragna ananta and i believe that
they were
helping host the tata steel chess india
events
so they've been doing a lot for chess
and kaspersky right below there
they've been sponsoring the world
championship and a lot of video events
for a really really long time
they make antivirus software which is
widely used and a lot of other products
that are
really popular in russia so we've got a
lot of
really strong teams i also like the
state bank of mongolia i want to mention
them because they have
one of mongolia's best grand masters uh
on the
top board there and they really have
some of the very best players
in mongolia and i just like the
the fact that that team is closely got
tied together lots of players
on the national team representing
obviously one of the most important
companies
in mongolia here so those players i
think
probably know each other well and have a
great team spirit
for sure and for our closest watchers
who are long-time chess fans
there's these are the european club cup
so you may recognize some of these names
like alkaloid there in group
f uh there are some familiar names and
they
represent uh their companies well and
they also
put together strong teams for these
international competitions
absolutely i'm also just drawn to the
european
patent office the hague they must have
very interesting and complex jobs and i
have a feeling that they're very
organized so we'll see how that carries
through into their play
definitely and i'm just so many
different
participants so many different players
from all around
the globe it's a truly international
event and well we're
about to have liftoff i see some games
getting
started here they're going to creep in
so let's just pull up uh
any old game here i think that we have
some from the
team optivar you mentioned uh david
pardon pro simon
and he's the white pieces against
someone who's much lower than he is
right he'll obviously be looking for a
win here optivar is one of the stronger
teams
with anish gary on board one um and part
of simon
international master here uh but they're
going to
they're gonna have a challenging time
moving on to the final on sunday of
course
the format here is that there are six
rounds we've had one round
we're in round two right now it is just
getting underway there are four more
rounds to go
one more today three more tomorrow and
then the top
team in each of the eight pools goes to
a bracket a knockout in the finals that
means that you have to be like the first
of 93 teams in your pool that's
very very difficult it doesn't matter
how strong your team is
you have to deliver in a very
very impressive way to be able to move
on to the finals on sunday
you don't get any missteps if you do
another team is taking
that place that you really hope for in
the finals that's
true indeed and for a team like optivar
i think their team rating is misleading
in the other direction we don't know
from their board
four just how strong she is their top
three boards are well known and niche
geary of course
being the most famous the bunch but if
she can perform
better than her rating which has not
been stabilized doesn't seem like she
plays many tournaments
they could actually really win this
thing and we have magnus carlsen's game
so i am not going to
waste any more time he is playing anton
corbeau we see the rating in the
parenthesis there
27 37 for anton corbett magnus carlson
at 2827 and
we have d4d5 so sam what are you
expecting from this one
i am just expecting a great match you
know who korabov reminds me of
is vasilia vonchuk a countryman another
player
who's just over the past three decades
been one of the best players
in the world also been a very very
difficult matchup for magnus carlson
i think both ivan chuk and korobov have
kind of a sharp but also positional
style
that's very unique very flexible and
i think that they've both been kind of
difficult matchups for carlson and
they've also been
to be honest a little bit streaky on a
good day i really think korobov is one
of those players who can beat
absolutely anybody in the world
including magnus carlson
and i think carlson you know kind of
knows that and respects that
about korobov when he comes to play he's
just
very very difficult and i think he also
played
one of the magnus tour events
and really performed very well there and
was
uh close to leading at some point over
the summer
there have been so many events of the
tour at this point that it's hard to
remember all the details
but it'll be really exciting to watch
this whole game as it unfolds
absolutely korvov has taken part in the
grand chess tour
which is a series of events comprised of
the best players
in the world he was a wild card i
remember he beat vichy anand
in head to head in their game he was one
of the top finishers so
he is well established in the upper
echelons of chess
right now he has put his queen on c2
bishop on d3
lining up towards the black king but
black is very solid
we see a change in pawn structure
typically that means black is either
playing for
pawn b5 thanks to this pawn c6 but that
pawn can become a weakness
if you played b5 or e5 in the center so
this is i would say a solid approach
thus far from magnus
and we'll see how he continues uh right
now
and while this kind of game is getting
underway we're still early in the
opening phase and
not yet at the critical moment we can
mention that magnus is playing for
kindred group
they of course have many kind of brands
incorporated into kindred group and that
includes unibet
so they've been doing sports betting for
a really long time
they've been connected with magnus
carlsen and
i think that magnus carlsen is a player
who really believes
in you know this kind of stuff fantasy
sports betting as a way to
help drive some money into the game to
help drive interest into the game
and so this is a company that i really
think that he's kind of
aligned with in terms of their goals for
how to grow chess
you know beyond just um being sponsored
by them i really think this is a strong
company that he feels connected to well
if you made me
into a betting man i would not bet
against magnus carlson in chess matches
and he has been the top fantasy football
that is
soccer to americans a player in the
world he was the number one ranked
player so he
has a keen interest in um sports
spending and
fantasy in particular so it's not just
about the betting it's that competitive
angle he's talked about this in
interviews
where hey he was striving to be the best
fantasy
player on the planet and he did achieve
that so he's just
world champion in chess in all
disciplines and then he also
dabbles and successfully so in fantasy
football so right now
rook d1 was played you see this weird
pawn structure for black right a6 b7 cc
e6 s7 that bishop on c8 doesn't feel
so good but part of the reason a6 is
played for black is that when you play
b5
you can follow up with c5 and your pawn
on a6 defends that pawn that goes to b5
so a6 may seem
like a bit slow to many people like
what's the idea it
looks like you're aiming for some kind
of b5 or c5 but taking away the b5
square
from white absolutely and
of course i think that many amateur
players might look at this position and
just assume
that white is better because white has
kind of expanded
up through the fourth rank and black is
still only on
black's third rank and further back but
black's position is
very very flexible black is ready to
expand
at some point it's very hard to contain
those b5 c5 and e5
breaks in a way that guarantees white an
advantage
and of course in round one we saw magnus
playing the king's gambit against his
opponent who he outraded
enormously but here against korabov he's
playing some mainline repertoire
and really trying to you know bring his
theory to bear
that said this is a 10-2 game and
he's down to six minutes and 44 seconds
so we would maybe think that he's in his
prep and that doesn't necessarily appear
to be the case he is thinking at this
point
and the computer is indicating that this
position is fine
probably this position has been played a
number of times
but he's trying to figure out how he
gets that
equality that he's looking for is black
what's the right way to play
and having used almost four of your 10
minutes up to this point
is a bit of an eyebrow razor it is
indeed and
it changes the trajectory of the game
when you push a pawn it cannot move
backwards so
if magnus intends to challenge the d4
pawn and he plays b5 first
but he could play e5 in which case you
do not have
the same pawns but if you play for c5
and then we get some kind of capture
then we have pawns on the same files so
he's trying to figure out the way to go
he plays b5
an aggressive approach hitting the
bishop and now
a korbovov has a choice to make do you
stay on the diagonal
of a2 to g8 or do you go elsewhere does
bishop d3 the move because that looks
threatening on the king side but then
i'm in the rook's way so these
little moves they really add up and he
chose bishop a2 and
look at that sam you see the engine bar
there
it's starting to go a bit down in
black's favor bishop a2 looks like a
good move
what did you do wrong you moved your
bishop to safety but that may have been
an
imprecise choice and thus magnus might
have a way to
start taking over the board and seizing
the initiative
absolutely and i know one thing that you
absolutely hate robert is the eval bar
it can be a shortcut that really
prevents a lot of instructive
thinking when you're spectating a game
um the other thing to think about
is that early in the game in an opening
position like this
where korobov and carlson have so much
experience
is often that the eval bar is wrong now
it's probably correct in indicating that
bishop a2
might not have been the best move but a
lot of people watching
may also see carlson playing b5 and see
that
at that point the eval bar went from
about equal to
an advantage for korobot and you know
without taking a
a much deeper look than we're going to
be able to take while spectating this
102 game
we can't really know exactly what's
going on but when you're dealing with
these small advantages
in the opening oftentimes carlson
korobov
these top players are actually more
precise
than the eval bar when you're looking at
small differences in the opening phase
that's right and also these tiny
advantages come and go in the blink of
an eye
and c5 that's a principle move taking on
c5 now magnus is a choice how do you
take back you choose the bishop i think
for some
the knight capture would seem more
natural because well i'm getting my
knight more advanced i'm opening my
bishop
but you see the eval bar then goes in
white's favor so
these decisions are very tricky and i
like bishop takes c5
because b4 still is an option you can
drop your bishop back
instead of staying on the d file which
can be prone to attack
you can move like white did on the a7 g1
diagonal
i've always really kind of enjoyed these
positions for black
it's a bit over optimistic but once i
saw the game
uh rutley v versus rubenstein 1907
as a young player i just always been
attracted to positions where you might
be able to get the bishops on these
diagonals
there's a lot of tactics that can arise
you know with bishop b7 bishop b6 corbat
is probably too strong
to allow anything like that to happen
but there's still just a lot of pressure
to deal with and it's easy to allow
magnus to get an edge and to really
start pressing this position
and maybe another thing to mention as
the players are thinking here
is that magnus really really needs a win
now
corbat is a player against whom magnus
would normally
be happy to get a draw against with the
black pieces of course
magnus is always looking to win against
every player he faces but
korobov is 27-37 you know he's
definitely a player that magnus respects
but playing board one here for kindred
that is going to it's it's a position
where magnus needs to win
if kindred is going to have a hope to
get into the finals
magnus is going to need to go 6-0 that's
just the truth of it
so he's really got to try to get the
full point in this position
it's an unrated team event and
magnus needs six out of six if his team
is going to make it through
and that's a lot of pressure to put on
even the world champion winning
games just on demand with the black
pieces against super grandmasters
not that easy and knight absolutely
played by korabov and look at magnus go
bishop b7
quick response giving up the bishop by
saying
you know at this high level we tend to
talk about the bishop pair being
the all-important thing hey my rooks
quickly come into c8 my bishop on b7
is better than your bishop on a2 and
that's the
small differences in position that we
need to assess that this bishop on a2 is
staring into a kind of brick wall of a
pawn structure because the pawn e6 is
defended by another pawn
whereas the bishop one b7 is superior as
it aims in the board's longest diagonal
and a pawn is not blocking its path
absolutely and this is a position where
the
engine is indicating that white might be
a little bit better or it's equal
but it definitely feels to me like a
position where i'd be a bit concerned
with the white pieces you know that
i've got that bishop on c1 it's not
looking so hot rook on a1 that bishop on
a2 i'm not so sure about it's
kind of biting on granite and black has
really good control over e4 and seems to
have a bit more of a fluid development
and it feels from a human perspective i
think
like it's at least a little bit more
easy to play for agnes
i think most would agree and black is
fully developed at that you
all your minor pieces out you can put a
rook on c to work on d8 the question
becomes what pieces do you want to see
traded
the bishops will show off their might as
this
one on c1 gets out to d2 and maybe to c3
or even b4
depending on what happens in the
position and look and magnus go
sorry what was that of a bishop getting
out to d2 and elsewhere
no i'm going to bring my knight in and i
can just take your bishop off but i
don't think that white's in any
danger unless you do something kind of
hectic
i think white's decision is solid and
horrible can play for more perhaps he
should play for more
with moving the knight trying to replace
the knight with a pawn on f3 if you can
get a pawn on f3 and e4
and i'll just make a random move just to
show that if you can get pawns on f3 and
e4
that bishop on b7 suddenly doesn't look
so good because the pawn chain is strong
for white and this bishop on c1
now has a whole diagonal to work with
absolutely very sophisticated
kind of setup here for white but this is
just a very very effective way to play
and it looks like korobov is going for
it
without that dark squared bishop for
magnus
f3 and e4 is a structure where it's very
hard for him to kind of take advantage
of the soft spots which are the dark
squares
so he's pushing forward with e5 if we
were going to see something aggressive
in this game
for either player what do you think it
would be um how would a player really
try to imbalance things and push for a
win
it's a great question and i'll say for
starters the bishop 182 is i was going
to say maybe reroute that
but now it's turned into a green piece
it's a happy piece as the pawnee sticks
out of the way but the knight gets to f5
i just like the coordination of black's
pieces if you ever try to play b4 watch
out for that c3 square
and maybe magnus can quickly go for an
attack because his bishop on b7 is
strong and he plays his queen of g5 and
g5
pretty clear that if you didn't do
anything about it there is a problem
down on g2 so if you move your knight
there's never where else to go but
knight d6 and i can just
even take your knight because there's a
mate on g2 also like knight c3
is not out of the question threatening
the checkmate and
threatening your queen and your rook all
at once that's just
a dev saying i like that you had a free
night and you still found an even better
move well done
yeah this looked pretty good to me so
don't take the knight go for the
checkmate and the queen under attack so
knight g3 played of course
to block the queen's threat on the g2
square and
sam i think we can both speak from
experience that when you get a position
that
looks good and you're aggressive as
black but then you
suddenly get pushed back a little bit
and the bishops can shine so
do you get the feeling maybe just me
right now that cora is going to get out
of this
and if he gets his like f3 e4 at some
point than the bishop once he was happy
or
am i looking too much in that bishop
advantage for what
uh you're being more sophisticated
than me um you're describing something
that i've experienced many times
i would go for magnus's position in a
heartbeat
i really like long diagonal pressure
this pretty night on e4
and i've played many kinds of attacks
like this with the black pieces and i
have been pushed back
and i have ultimately lost games in a
lot of cases where
i was like where did i go wrong so i'm
liking black
but i can absolutely relate to
everything you're saying
this is a position where maybe
eventually the bishop pair
is going to really be very very potent
and
black's real asset here is some activity
which is of course legitimate
and some pressure maybe on that long
diagonal but those are kind of
short-term
gains now it looks like we're going to
get a liquidation and maybe
this is going to be the second game
along with nihal soren versus
geary where we actually see one of the
top seeds held back
and uh they might not be able to really
get winning chances
the position is simplifying the pawn
structure
is symmetrical how is either player
really going to push for a win if more
pieces get traded on the d
file that's a great question and
i mean one of the things is bishop 1a2
is staring at his f7 pawn so we keep
talking about this bishop on b7
but the bishop on a2 is actually a
sneakily good piece as well
it looks like it should be relatively
level i see that the engine
says completely equal but that's so
misleading there's so so much life left
and magnus only has a minute
and 30 seconds on his clock and he needs
to win for his team
so i think that here he was 94 and you
see
white's advantage creeping up a little
bit it's starting to likewise position
then going back down and you said this
the depth issue of the engine means that
it's not seeing
too far along and in fact players can
out calculate the engine when it's on
lower depth levels
absolutely and when there's in this case
two open files but often you're kind of
dealing with you know one open file and
in this case the open file that seems to
matter at the moment is the d
file uh and there and the players are
challenging
each other on that open file a lot of
times that leads very very quickly to
exchanges
and i think this is true in this case
it's hard to avoid
some more exchanges and we just saw
another pair of works leave the board
it's very very possible that the final
pair of rooks might leave the board as
well
it seems like rook d1 is a very very
natural move for korboff to play here
um and you know as pieces leave the
board
how is either player really going to
press of course for his team i think
korobav holding magnus carlson to a draw
here even with the white pieces maybe
holding isn't the right word because
he's such a great player
that could put his team in a great spot
to get the match victory against kindred
carlson's team it's very difficult to
balance the hey i might have a slightly
better position now from the white side
and i'm playing magnus carlsen i would
love to beat him
but then you take a step back wait i'm
playing on a team here so the most
important thing is that the team wins
a win over magnus carlson that's a
lifetime achievement but
right now it's not about that because if
i play to win maybe i lose the game
because i'm
not thinking objectively and i think
that kobov he will be objective he's
ahead on the clock
he's just trying to figure out the right
way to push forward and you don't want
to say
let me just make a draw because you're
still thinking about results you need to
play the position
and rook d1 does feel like a good start
absolutely and
i don't think that korobov has been
playing for a draw here i think he's
just been playing his
chess and the opening selected in this
game is one oh rook c1
so he is optimistic not playing for a
draw i would have thought
that rook d1 was kind of the playing for
a draw move
in this case um but he's keeping pieces
on the board and he's got ideas
of bishop takes f7 as you point out and
rook c7 are just for c7 and that's
that's intense so he's still bringing
pressure and he does have
you know more than double carlson's time
on the clock
um i really would would feel
like a draw would be a great result for
korobar from a team standpoint because i
think that his team is outraging
kindred on the other boards but it looks
like he's going for more than that
and right now magnus under a minute
corbett is doing very well on the clock
two minutes 41 seconds queen he said
that's a very smart move by magnus
bringing the queen back to defend
but now magnus is on the defensive so he
needs to figure out wait
my team needs me to win i don't see
anything that i can do that bishop on b7
it looks good it's aesthetically
pleasing but is it doing all that much
how are you going to team up on this g2
pawn that's the absolute
definitely feels weaker than the g2 pawn
at this point
maybe queen c2 and queen into c7 queen
c2 cannot be met by rook c8
because you will trade down actually
yeah
no you can't do that i miscounted for a
moment
uh and after queen f8 uh white will have
an extra bishop in the final position
exactly a very forcing sequence and it
looks like cub movement played
b4 and g6 which was b4
on one hand gives you the c5 square is a
nice
place to put your rook on the other hand
it makes a3 a little looser so if black
can somehow get into the third rank or
go after this a3 pawn it can become a
target
and i think that what g6 i mean g6 is
making left it makes a lot of sense of
course
i think g6 is also intending king g7 at
some point very very likely
and then maybe something like pawn to f6
i don't know if you want to play that
and soften the seventh rank
you might need to be very careful about
that but you can potentially shift
some of the pawns forward over time
taking uh
pressure off of the pawn and f7 and the
king on g8 that's definitely where
core above has been putting some
pressure although
it's looking more and more like things
are going to liquidate from here we've
been saying liquidation is likely
and we've got some interesting moments i
don't know if magnus can and that's the
problem it was queen d3
but even because queen a2 is potentially
possible going for the f7
and max is 23 seconds he does not have
that much time to figure this out
that's a a fascinating move i was
definitely expecting queens
to likely leave the board after the
queen came down on the d-file
but of course you're right and they
don't have to leave the board
korobov can keep them on and i think
that
what i should say sam that could be a
losing move as well because quinn a2 may
hit f7
but you can potentially give up some
with queen e4 and you see the
eval bar i was looking at this right
bishop f7 check the king moves away and
this is a problem the rook gets to de1
and this king is actually very weak for
white so that's why
this move would not be good to keep the
queens on the board and he takes on f7
first that way when he trades queens
he'll have rook c7 check fancy tactic
that liquidates and after the capture on
b7
there's also going to be a capture here
on
a3 as well right yes because the queens
have to get traded
and so that's why the computer is
calling this equal and white hasn't won
a pawn
all of that happens in the blink of an
eye um
is there still any edge for either
player here
um i mean i guess i would kind of the
king is coming up the board you have to
be a little careful about the king
invading so i guess this is going to
lead to a trade
that's why rook a4 here to make sure
that you don't wait too long
and king h3h4 g5 might happen
the rook capturing on b4 will prevent
the king's
invasion if you can arrange it in the
right way
still looks a little tricky potentially
yeah it feels like white is the one who
can
definitely create some chances although
this is
not chances i think we've seen better
pawn structures before
and double isolated pawns two sets of
them for white
magnus may have 16 seconds left but he
has more than enough time to hold his
rookie four
and just go after the e pawns both of
them will fall
with a such a fractured structure here
and the white king not having gotten
active of course
wait it's okay it's uh
i was just gonna say you're worried
about rugby one yeah me too i'm like
this part
is actually a stronger pass pawn
yeah the the idea potentially after a g4
of like rook b1 burying the king on h2
and then suddenly the b-pawn racing down
the board was definitely scary for a
moment
you can never let your guard down again
if you want one
where'd be one and it was so long and
you're going to lose these pawns
madness suddenly is turning us around
and corvo can't move
why did the king go back that way that's
insane oh my gosh
and the king can't move so he has to
move the rook at some point and then
this king
there could be a stalemate trick though
you have to be careful precise of your
magnus because
i want to give away both of my pawns and
i'll check your king forever
and that could be so exciting a
potential like sacrifice of the rook to
achieve still made
okay where's the wind the rook is trying
to come back to b5 you can move rook to
c1 and up to c3 to defend the pawn this
way he does do that
but it looks like the eval bar dropped
so it doesn't love this decision
although it feels like white's still a
little bit stuck because the g3 pawn
falls
and now the king comes back we're going
to have to look at this afterwards and
figure out what the engine was loving
about the position
and of course it's it's not over but
the engine is saying that the chances
seem to have gone away at this point
right rotates g3 came back and the king
is freed up so that king
was caught on h2 couldn't move there
still is something to play for for
magnus you know him he does not just
agree in a draw
even if it looks that it should be g3
check can be thrown in at some point
he checks and puts upon b2 and corbo is
15 seconds and
takes is his king in time to get this
pawn it looks like it is so if you take
on g2
the king will run right this way and the
pawn will be
grabbed right and it seems to matter i
think also that the white rook is doing
a good job of making it hard for the
black king to approach as well
yes and i wonder if the engine
evaluation was accurate or if there were
stalemate tactics that it overlooked but
by the way
rook check could have won the rook but
then this pawn would have promoted so
don't just go win
a rook when the pawn is on the seventh
ranker in this case the second rank so
it looks like you're going to sacrifice
your rook for the b-pawn white is going
to end up pushing the g
pawn and black off the sack but whatever
rook d4 worked before though be careful
oh gosh magnus we see from magnus you
know kind of a little bit of a head bob
there saying all right it's a draw you
know
um seems clear that magnus is you know
aware that the rook is about to
sacrifice on b2 of course he is because
he's
the greatest player in the world maybe
in world history um
and you know he's just kind of tuning
out a little bit saying all right
there's nothing more i've got that one
trick with
the rook coming to f4 and before and
corb just gives up the rook and make
sure that that doesn't happen
yes and the game is drawn so they split
the point and that's
a win for i would say for spare bank in
that
one because kindred needs magnus to win
their games based on the
ratings of the other boards let's keep
on going plenty of good games
left i'm gonna click on this one i see
time travel between
kavalusky with the black piece it's a
feeding master and feeding master
kadatsky
with white and look at this position sam
where it's extra material for
white in terms of oh wait sorry it's not
extreme whichever black i didn't even
eat no black has an extra knight yeah
like i'm like looking i was like wait a
second
i calculated this king as like a rook
and i was like whoa but
even though it's an extra night the evas
is equal now
and it's because of all these past pawns
and then it dropped immediately like
what is this i would have immediately
played e6
the the engine is you know parsing this
so quickly but
of course on a human level this is
incredible
what was better than e6 right e6 somehow
h3 which looks like a good move somehow
a bad move
uh this i don't understand anything here
a while ago
okay watch out that's a discover check
where's the king going and if you move
the king there's king d7 hitting the
rook
wait a second i was exclusively focusing
on these past pawn tactics but this rook
d2 i
a rook b2 idea is just so nice yeah
and the king is drawn by perpetual i
guess because the king has the
c6 square to run away to wow knight
shield what a brave move to play in time
trouble
okay so if the bishop moves he dropped
the c stamp on he brings the king right
back
protecting the pawn and we might get a
repetition here
um this is what a weird repetition
wow okay uh so at least at the end
perfect play as the computer agrees with
the draw by repetition there
uh just like with magnus's game you know
we've got to look at that
again afterwards with a computer because
it's really hard to figure out you know
what uh was going on after some of these
moves definitely
and george meyer is playing for grandkid
let's go over to his game it looks like
well it's well how many what's the
material account because i just missed
calorie material
it looks like white is up a minor piece
for
two pawns so that's why the engine loves
georg's position
he is extra material three points for
two and
he is coordinated very well so the queen
is being pushed back and he then can go
after these
queenside pawns you start attacking them
very very beautiful uh coordination here
from georg he's
always just had an incredible style for
coordination i think that that's one of
the things that when you look at george
games
kind of immediately stands out in a
beautiful way is just that his pieces
are always
working together really really well and
of course george is one of those players
who can beat anybody in the world
including vladimir kramnik who he has
defeated in a
a really uh incredible and famous game
and potentially magnus carlsen should
they
manage to face off and of course georg
is also bored one for
grinka the grinkerbock who hosts the
grinker tournament which is an
incredible tournament
and they are one of the top seeds in
this event so they have a very very good
shot
of making it to the final and george
looking like he's
doing everything right by his team at
this point yes and their fourth board
in agrest is like nearly 2 300 feet a so
their team
is quite balanced some teams have a very
highly rated first board and their
fourth board
maybe a newer player in this case every
single board's experience
and can compete with all the top players
in the world so i just want to go back a
quick moment here because i see
where the piece was given up i mean
black's position at this point looked
fine just a couple moves ago
and after bishop h6 the knight came to
d2 and after queen a5
it was trying black was trying to go and
pin this piece
and win it but after b4 instead of just
saying all right maybe queen a5 wasn't
the right choice i should my queen back
there was a knight sacrifice on b4
likely thinking that this knight
couldn't be defended so easily
but a move like e3 also comes to mind
but bishop c3 is the most precise
kicking the queen back while defending
the knight and this was not
a correct piece sacrifice from black
right
very very optimistic it's tough when
you're playing
a grandmaster a player who's outraging
you by
quite a lot but you sometimes just have
to be patient say all right i'm going
back
and i'm going to hope that my
grandmaster opponent makes a mistake
later in the game
i think that being patient is one of the
most difficult things
against a high-rated opponent because
frankly time is on their side like you
are more likely to make mistakes as the
game continues
but you can't let that push you into
making decisions that aren't justified
like knight takes before
that's right and we can come back here
we're going to pull up the game
of yakovanko another super grandmaster
who is playing in this one you see the
rating in prezi 2911
but playing an international master i
think that 2030 rating
that's just the online rating for the
players account
that's a teeny bit misleading wouldn't
you say
that is a teeny bit misleading uh i
actually know
uh pyotr um and he heads up infoshock
which is one of the most popular kind of
chess content
uh outlets in uh in poland it's a
fantastic
organization they do tournaments they do
blogs
all kinds of great stuff definitely
check it out if you are
looking for polish content and of course
his rating of 2030 is
totally inaccurate he's a very strong i
am and he's playing a good game so far
against
yakovenko and he's got a really unique
position here like the pawns hanging
back on e2 it hasn't advanced yet
and he's got you know a kind of nice
control over the light squares
it's a hyper modern setup but a very
very playable one for white
and as you're pointing out the pawns
feel safe and sound for white but black
has
better space because of this pawn on c5
and e5
taking control of the center but with
the pawns on b2 protecting c3 e2
predicting d3 it's hard to see how black
makes progress and i just looked up
pyotr's rating 2411. so i hope that
yakovanko didn't just look at the
chess.com rating here and say
oh okay i'm playing somebody who's 2000.
you should always play the board
regardless but this is where you can be
misled
by the rating next to the name and okay
bishop b5 queen d6
at some point sam i believe a5 is what
white wants to play for and
well right now to try to open up the a
file and make this rook useful
and it's very very interesting many many
things can happen from here
uh the game is kind of in full tension
mode uh
who knows how the game is going to
develop from this point on and of course
what you're saying about
just not kind of taking your opponent's
rating at face value
is incredibly important in this
tournament
i think everyone should just assume that
they're playing
some 2400 blitz player who's never
played a feed a rated game
in their life because it's going to be
true for some of the players in this
particular event
and you don't want to be the more
experienced player
who makes some decisions that you would
not make if you realize what your
opponent's kind of true skill was
i think there are definitely some
players who have a rating of like 1 000
who actually are very experienced online
players and are much much stronger than
that
yes and it's easy to just be lulled into
a false sense of security i think that
jakovenko he sees the title and he
probably has
known this player uh pyotr when and i
mean just very strong and right now with
the queen on h4
it's such a strange position sam because
white's playing on both sides you're
looking wait is bishop h6 happening
or is pontig's b6 happening and the
answer might be both and jakovenko plays
a great move
f5 which plays on both sides of the
board as well it looks like it's only
playing on the king side
but you also are opening up your rook to
the defense of the h7 square if for some
reason your king
got in some trouble and the rook can
slide to the king side as well i think
that black is trying to
push through with a move like f4 right
yakovenko is meeting this kind of hyper
modern
setup from pyeonter with just direct
central aggression which is very
classical
it's absolutely what i think we would
advise you know most of the amateur
players in the chat to do
and it certainly looks challenging to
meet
even if the computer is saying that this
position is equal and of course the
computer is usually right
it definitely feels easier to make
a game losing error at this point for
white to allow
an f4 or an e4 something to crash
through
uh in a decisive way that said it
it's really hard to see how that would
work right away and maybe if black
overextends you know white can also get
the chances in the game
well i also am looking at this workout
thing you're trying to meet f4
but white's combination of moves
probably not
as precise as possible because these
rooks at some point can slide back to
the a file
that's the board's only fully open file
and a rook can then go down to the
square like a2
and cause problems for white on the
queen side this is why we
tell everybody you know look at the
entire board the action may
look like it's taking place in the king
side but if you're not careful
all of a sudden queenside infiltration
happens and that can be a problem
another idea
i would have to mention is bishop
retreat and queen up to d5
but if this bishop leaves d5 and white's
bishop will go to c4
with a pin on the diagonal so you want
to line up the checkmate just not
possible yet
absolutely and i think one of the things
that you're pointing out
is that that space gives yakivenko
so many more maneuvering options access
potentially to the a file his rooks can
swing
all over the eighth and seventh ranks to
attack different sensitive points in the
white position
he has the ideas of pushing these pawns
like he's just done with f4
he has bishop b7 and queen d5 so many
more options
that said none of them are clearly
decisive and
there was a a clip recently
of daniel narenditsky talking about the
spatial advantage and saying that a
spatial advantage is
you know not really an actual advantage
it's something that you kind of have to
turn
into a more tangible advantage and so
far jacovenko hasn't managed to do that
he's got to find some way to convert
this theoretical spatial advantage
into something concrete you know picking
up material or
actually making a direct attack finding
some weak points that he's able to
target
you know creating a a structural issue
so far
still very very difficult to figure out
the path forward now e4
is a very very committal move um
[Music]
what should happen now did you just pull
the bishop back
bishop e6 i really liked that decision
because had
you taken on passant which was possible
then the queen can just
take back on e3 and then the e5 pawn
feels like the biggest target that's an
isolated pawn that i'm staring at
and in general in this position the
bishop on b5
is doing a ton it is holding down the d3
pawn
which looks like a pawn that black wants
to pile up on and so for the time being
that pawn is safe but you talk about how
spatial advantages you need to
prove something i mean this is already
now clear he
induced e4 and now this d3 pawn is a
long-term target
the king on g2 feels much less safe than
the king on jade look at all these
pieces around the black king
and this pawn on f4 is a threatening
piece
and this bishop on b5 while it defends
d3 it doesn't help on the king side so
if at some point bishop g4 can be played
the bishop on g b5 rather can't help
get back but instead i think yaakov will
rush this and
it looks like we have an even trade-off
here and the computer immediately
demonstrated a lot of skepticism about
the capture on g3 as you're saying
uh one other thing about the bishop 1v5
is it it almost feels
kind of out of play like it seems like
it's a well-placed piece
kind of up on the b5 square like if it's
the night we would talk about it being
placed
you know in an outpost or something like
that uh but in this position
you know what is that bishop really
doing black's bishop is kind of
restraining it you can't pull that
bishop
back to c4 because you don't want to
accept that pawn structure weakness if
there's a trait of bishops on c4
so that bishop feels a little bit stuck
it's hard for
white to figure out what to do exactly
with that bishop
that said after like queen e3 here
you know how is giacomenko making any
progress in the position
i think as soon as that queen moves to
play h5 because
okay something important to note is we
have even material right where you have
a queen
a bishop and five pawns per side but
black actually has an
extra pawn if you look at it from where
the pawns are so black is an extra pawn
from the g and h files aldo in the flank
white has an extra pawn in the center
but your central
extra pawn cannot push thanks to all
three of these pieces you are not
pushing that pawn to d4 whereas black
can play h5
black can play g5 maybe play h4 and that
can create a past pawn that white will
be tied down to
all right so question here and actually
white's
last move makes this question more
relevant uh who wants the queens
on the board who wants the queens off
the board it depends on how they're
traded you'll note that jakobanko said
you can take me but look at my king
coming up and i get to keep
my outside passport potential here so i
think the queen trade uh
it favors black in terms of creating uh
the past pawn
but for white probably said all right
there's nothing uh better to do and i
don't think of this past pawn situation
winning i personally really like black's
chances here this pawn
okay come here the bishops come to e6
and then h4 at some point
and so here probably bishop e6 right and
the king and pawn
in game might very well be losing just
by force for white in fact king and pawn
in games
are usually by force whether it's
winning drawing or losing it's by force
if you calculate deep enough in a king
upon end game you can
achieve some measure of truth uh i want
to say that
uh i don't remember which uh famous
author said this but
one famous author said that the only
evaluations for king and pond in games
are
winning drawing or losing if you look
deep enough
or transposition to a queen end game
and you can't really talk about slight
advantage or clear advantage necessarily
in a king and pawn in game because
they're so forcing by nature
and we see a forcing decision here but
the engine didn't love that
maybe it was waiting for a more timely
decision to push that pawn but in a
bullet scramble right now white has 43
seconds counting down
you're looking can i get away with pawn
to d4 or does that actually help black
because this past pawn is really far off
the board and outside past pawns are so
valuable in the ending
because say the bishops get traded this
king will have to go
all the way to the h file and black's
king will then start playing in the
center of the board
where all the remaining pawns are so
this pawn is a decoy more than anything
and pyoter down to 20 seconds how is he
going to handle this
that allows g5 with a tempo and then
bishop h5 right
and then just try to trade off those
bishops it looks like yeah that looks
pretty good to me
and i'm guessing kyoto was relying on d4
as an idea trying to create a passport
of zone but it seems like it could be a
bit slow
still very very complicated we see that
the computer is saying you know like
negative
1 negative 2 or something like that that
does not necessarily mean it's decisive
um white or black is probably going to
win the white
bishop uh for the pawn
well maybe maybe you just promote by
force in some lines like king g3
king into f2 i i'm thinking that if you
manage to give up your bishop for the
h-pawn probably you can draw
but he's not sure you're going to it and
that's why bishop e6 was so good oh
and look at that i said he wasn't going
to allow it and then it went down to
zeros and this is how tricky end games
are
by force and here comes the pawn to h3
so leaving that sacrifice
was of this decision and the bishop is
going
uh to g4 to f3 and
you're just going to eliminate that
light square bishop and a big problem
for white is the king can't get in so
even
you know i would need to be able to take
your last pawn because if
black just goes in and promotes then the
king can come back and help out and this
king cannot enter for white the king
would have to go around
to f6 it's a very long journey and
unfortunately also the white pawns can't
really make progress
black has managed to push the pawn all
the way down to h2
and the pawn on e5 has just been sitting
there
not able to get up somewhere like e7
where there would actually be counter
play
and maybe in this case you just queen
okay i was expecting the bishop maneuver
without that yeah because the pawns on a
light square if this pawn were back on
b4 this would not be a good decision
jakovenko times this perfectly
takes on b5 the bishop can just go back
and then the bishop protects the b pawn
so even if this king were on b4
this setup with pawn b5 and bish 28 the
pawns on a light square defendant
and don't lose your bishop now the king
can't even catch the pawn
we'll get a promotion you're winning the
bishop for the pass pawn if you want
but it doesn't matter of course because
black is going to get a queen
i like the king f6 king g5 king
f4 maneuver like he's trying like a
ready in-game study kind of thing
to to move around with the king of
course there's
not quite enough tempos to make it
happen the
square of the pawn is too far advanced
the white king can't return but i like
the idea
i like that you know we we probably
mostly know
this famous ready in game study where
the king zigzags from h8 to e5 and then
catches this h-pawn you think you could
never catch
um and uh gutters trying to
create out of thin air kind of like that
study does some extra tempo but it's
it's not quite there in this particular
position and one of the largest problems
and we saw the
eval bar it fluctuated for like one move
when you are watching and you have that
evaluation bar you see oh wait there's
something that saves the day
piotr probably was feeling pretty
dejected at the point and we just
we'll look at it after we take a break
but just to show that a position once
more
when you get to a position like this
where you know that black is in charge
maybe there is a way to hold when you
have 16 seconds or whatever it was left
that's not gonna do the trick but you
just start feeling bad the trajectory of
the game has been from one where you
felt like you were holding off your
super grandmaster opponent to one we're
like
oh that's an outside pass pawn i've
studied enough chess played enough chess
to realize
my position isn't good and you could
actually lose the game before you
actually lose the game because mentally
you've kind of resigned in advance
and you don't find all your best chances
especially in a
time scramble situation and we see the
eval bar
the chat sees the eval bar that is such
a huge
influence for us mentally we're like
there's probably still a way to draw
and mentally piater you know might be
thinking that that
eval bar is at the bottom right now and
that the computer's just saying that
it's a win there's nothing to find
that's a mentality that is so difficult
to challenge in the computer error
but you have to kind of constantly keep
searching for the resources
even when it's very easy to kind of
think
that you know maybe this is just lost at
this particular point
i don't think that fiat was probably
quite there in this position but
as you say it's difficult you know your
opponent is pressing you're not sure if
there's a way to find it you have
seconds on the clock
piatra played a great game this was
really a fine effort against
a top gm in yakovenko great showing
unfortunately for him
didn't go his way for yandex they're
very happy that yakovanka won
and the second round of this fide
online world uh corporate championship
it is
over with we are going to take a break
and we just remind everybody before we
do
to use the command donate please if
you're able to
this is raising money for charity for
various funds so do
get involved if you can we would really
appreciate it but for now we will take a
break when we return sam and i will go
over
all that's just happened in round two
some exciting moments and there will be
round three ahead
[Music]
and we return two rounds in the books
from the
opening groups from the east here sam
it's been fun thus far some
top heavy matchups some upsets i
actually was talking to you during the
break about
a 500 point upset in one of the matches
that's
pretty great to see absolutely it's
fantastic we've got to find a way to
make it
easy to find all these upsets and really
showcase them because
there are so many players in this event
who just don't get to play a lot of
chess but maybe they're playing a lot
online maybe they're playing a lot in
their lunch breaks and such
and to get to go in to a team tournament
to represent their company with their
friends and
colleagues and to get that upset is
really an achievement and it feels so
good for these players when they're able
to do that
it certainly must and well you know this
wasn't an upset it was a
draw on one of the top boards but we
were looking at ants on korvo against
magnus carlsen that game for a while
so we can analyze where magnus let a
great position slip up because he was
really close
to actually winning this game and it
didn't look like he should
but one small slip here at this moment
where white went king h2 that looks like
a totally
reasonable fine choice but the problem
with putting the king on h2 is after
rook came to b1 the king is cut off
and the way this could do with rook to
b5 mistakes often come in pairs
you lose the e6 pawn you take h5 and the
winning way for magnus would have been
to slide his king over
to c6 to try to take away the b5 square
because the best way to defend against a
past pawn is by putting your rook behind
the pawn
so if the king started with king to d6
well note that this king
on h2 can't move so white would love to
get
rid of this pawn if that pawn didn't
exist i will sacrifice my rook
for a stalemate but because the pawn is
still here i'm actually trying to avoid
it
if you go rook to b5 i'll go king to c6
i'm trying to bring
my king up and ignore your pawn for now
before bringing my rook out after the
king defends the pawn it's a very
rich endgame here sam one you don't get
to see very often
absolutely i think that obviously magnus
is
famous for his in-game play he generates
these kind of rich complex difficult
decisions
for his opponent in the end game over
and over again we were really expecting
a draw in this game much earlier
and then we got here we saw king h2 and
we were both going
hey what about rook b1 the white king is
trapped and
of course that did happen but as you're
showing
the path to precisely take advantage of
that you know especially given that
white has
very serious stalemate resources in this
position is just
you know a very very narrow path so
generating this kind of winning position
uh
by magnus is just you know it's the
stuff that makes him
so amazing so impressive and the
greatest game player in the world
it didn't quite in this case with 10 20
seconds on the clock
manifest as a win because it was so hard
to find
the exact moves here but magnus created
these winning chances
and a real winning opportunity where i
think almost no one would have really
thought that he was going to be able to
press for a win
that's right and i just want to show a
stalemate a funny one if rookie 5 check
you know something like that takes but
it's black's turn so that's a king d6 e5
just to show what can happen is if you
play e6 and you take
you'll notice that this king has no
moves these pawns have no moves so
rookie five checks is
take my rook and i will just follow your
king no matter where it goes put my rook
right in front of you
and just i'm going to go from a5 to h5
you can't do anything eventually you
will have to
take the king the rooks rather you'll
run out of moves and that would be a
stalemate so
the key here is even if this pawn will
push up you're not
taking the pawn that's how magnets wins
the game instead of
taking the pawn you move your king away
from it and that way this rook
can't get to stop the pawn your king on
c6
takes away any kind of b file your king
still wants to run up and after e6 you
can
bring your rook out to then go take the
opponent once your rook takes the pawn
the king gets g1 but it's too late
because white has exceeded
black has his b3 pawn and black has the
idea
in just a moment of b2 and then like
rook h1
and then you promote that way although
you might not have to sacrifice the
brook
after b2 uh you're just able to move the
work out of the way
and then promote i was just sure that's
a nice thing to show everybody that
sometimes you give up the rook for
to be a forcing move so white doesn't
have time to promote and then you get a
queen with check
and then take care of the pawn so a nice
fun end game it wasn't ultimately a win
but there were chances out of thin air
and speaking of chances
this one here that we were looking at
between uh pyotr nguyen
and dimitri jacovenko it looked like
black was just dominating right this
position
the white king is stuck c5 covered d5
covered opposition
the king on a four very active and the
king releases the e5 pawn falls
but king f3 was actually a mistake and
we saw this during the game that the
evaluation
bar plummeted if you're thinking about
this from yakovanko's perspective
and the reason why is so difficult to
see
it's actually the move bishop c4
you don't think in this manner of like
i'm going to go promote my partner
you're thinking i'm going to sacrifice
my bishop for your pawn
but in fact your pawn is ready to
promote in the event of a bishop trade
and the queens will happen at the same
time
that's super instructive as you say it's
so hard to get into that mentality of
let's enter a pawn race like it feels
like the opponent's pawn is so far
advanced it feels like you would just
lose the pawn race
so there's kind of a mental block
against this idea of bishop
c4 you figure you're just losing that
and you need to find some way to give up
the bishop for the h pawn and then try
to draw the
end game by eliminating black's last
pawn that didn't turn out to be possible
so that's just a
fantastic and instructive resource right
because typically you give up the bishop
for this h pawn your king gets the b5
you take that last pawn
and that's how you make a draw but the
king can't get in so great
kind of for construction here by jacob
vancouver
fortress but usually a fortress means
like holding a draw no he just keeps the
king out
and so the king can't get in and bishop
c4 would have been that last try and as
we're talking about
black will go and promote but white
promotes as well and
funnier enough the side that promotes
first might be the side that's in more
trouble because that pawn on b6
very close to the white king this could
in fact have been a total turn
in white's favor absolutely very very
difficult even if the eval bar is saying
that this is equal
to draw especially with very very little
time on the clock keep in mind these are
rapid games this is 10-2
and so as great as these players are
there's going to be mistakes and you
need to think a lot about
the practical chances of the challenge
of getting these draws
uh even when the computer is saying oh
it's easy it's 0.00
now it's i mean easy is the last thing i
think about when i see this position
where you make
one mistake and the queens get traded
for example this king for white is so
close to that remaining pawn
it could be a losing king and pawning
game so we went through these two and
there is another one that you would
point out it was this game
between anisimov pablo nismo he's a
popular streamer and plays a lot of
chess
on chess.com title tuesdays he's well
known i need the black pieces here so
sam why don't you take us through this
because i think even the first move from
this position where white has the
advantage
might be a surprise to many well i think
you were focusing on this particular
middle game position so i actually
hadn't seen how black uh
developed their attack here i was
focused a little more on the end game
but i think you were mentioning that
black actually generated some chances
here by pushing the h
pawn here a little bit alpha zero style
um you know bent larson famously said
that when you're unsure what to do you
should push a rook pawn
this is a classic example it took you
know
uh i think the chess community
many decades and the development of
neural network engines to really
understand what bent larson was about by
pushing the h-pawn up the board
you create the situation where you might
be able to open lines
and disrupt the white king certainly the
black king is totally safe
the advance of the h pawn can only
endanger the white king
and not so much in this particular
position but
thematically in a lot of positions
pushing this pawn may allow things like
the pawn just
sinking itself into h3 gaining space and
gaining a lot of
end games where that pawn could
potentially
break through and win the end game so
this is very very instructive
and unfortunately for white just a few
moves later white did make a tactical
error
and black uh black managed to catch him
in a bit of a puzzlers moment
yeah i mean this moment here at h6 g3
the queen came to c5 is looking good for
white
the bishop pair his pawn d5 is isolated
your queen just got active
but after the hg hu queen e5 you have a
big trouble because this pawn g3 is
under attack if you ever push this pawn
to f4
give me those light squares even a
bishop h5 or queen
queen e3 yeah you're just in deep
trouble they're giving me such squares
so instead the move king f2 was played
and that's walking into
this nasty night for give up one night
to take back and then that's a fork
where and look at this didn't even take
the queen
that's high level player is it most of
us would just take the queen
which is a great move is it throwing in
a check and saying maybe i'll go
checkmate your king
and that's uh what he does he goes for
it and then he finally takes
gets the queen and plays bishop d3 so a
nice
sequence there for black to win the game
very very pretty
of course i think royal forks have
always been
one of the prettier elements in chess
especially for amateur
players it just kind of sticks together
so well the geometry is always really
really pleasing
and i think these kinds of patterns
where you get a royal fork and you drop
one knight in and then you lose it you
sacrifice it
and you have to drop the other knight in
as backup is
uh particularly nice in this case very
pretty geometry
very instructive geometry that's right i
think many
of our viewers if you're newer to chess
wait i can't put my knight to e4
because that pawn's there but you have
to think in that trading sequence right
one knight replaces the other as sam was
just talking about and that
wins more material than you give up so
it's a really nice find there by
anissimo and it all started with that h5
move because even if we just scroll to
this position
this wouldn't be an attack if there's a
white pawn on h2 and a black pawn
h7 or h6 but because he went in h5h4 and
then created
a softer target the shield that the
white king had
was dented and then there was a tactical
sequence to win it
for black so nice game there and well i
mean
so many good games we're spoiled for
choice hundreds and hundreds of players
taking part in every single round here
sam it's just been so fun thus far
absolutely i'm a huge
fan of this kind of event i really like
spectacular chess i like these kinds of
you know attacking games and i've always
loved
the olympiad the world cup this event
right here
where you just have so much chess to
absorb like you go
in between the rounds and look at the
games on chess.com events or
other locations and you just see all
these games like whoa that's a beautiful
queen sacrifice right there that's a
beautiful checkmate that's an
upset it's just such a rich uh
you know array of chess to enjoy and
in some extent there may be too much to
process but you can take your time these
games are not leaving
the internet you can check them out at a
later time and well we'll
check everybody out in a later time
because we're going to take a short
break we will be back
soon and when we return we are getting
set for round three and the action is
certainly heating up
[Music]
and we're back for the feed a online
world corporate chess championship
i'm grand master robert hess alongside
me is national master sam copeland sam
two rounds in the books we are about to
get round three you and i were just
speaking about some of these really big
matchups that we have in store for us
going forward
absolutely we've got some very very even
match-ups
i think we have anishigiri has his first
nope not his first
his second grandmaster opponent because
in round one he played nihal saran
that's the
kind of strong event that this is we'll
be paying a lot of attention to the
optivaire match up which will be
really really close last round i think
that magnus carlson's kindred team
did unfortunately lose their match very
exciting game
for the world champion but we've just
got so
many interesting and competitive teams
to watch we're going to take a quick
look at the standings
try to highlight some of the teams here
that are
on top of their pool and have a good
chance to qualify through
on sunday yeah we see starting in
the aaa group you have teams like the
bank of russia
you have uh in there even looking down
past the four points right that's in
first place but
airbus france looks pretty cool there
amazon europe i've been looking at their
standings
all these teams have a chance for sure
and in
group b we were talking about gronka
from the beginning
they still look real powerful but so
does jakovenko and yandex there and
group
as the fourth team in the list there
absolutely great companies great
supporters of
chess especially grinka as we've
mentioned they've run a super tournament
every year unfortunately i do believe
last year's was canceled due to covid
but we hope that they are able to bring
that back in 2021
um and they've got georg meyer and iana
agrest
hannah marie kleck a host of great
players on that team
but there is a lot of competition uh and
as we look at these teams as they're
playing their matches we should really
be paying a lot of attention to the game
points in that first column there
because that is a very very important
tie break it's not just important that
the teams win their matches
they also often need to get a very big
score if they
potentially end up in a tie at the end
of tomorrow
that will be a huge tie break they need
as many individual game wins as well as
match wins to move on
that's right and morgan stanley they're
in group c they're taking on wasco
so some top heavyweight matchups in
store for us and we see the rest of the
standings
we have in group d slav group i think
ilya smirn
is on the top board for them you have
pay pal bulgaria we've talked
quite a bit about them with erenberg and
stefanova on the top two boards
spare bank trade union we've seen from
them they have
anton korbov so just strong players
throughout this whole
standings here all these teams are very
powerful and as we get further and
further
into this tournament the teams at the
top will be
really fielding title players and highly
rated players
throughout their sports absolutely
uh and i think we wanted to take a
moment to talk about the
charity side of this event these
companies many of them have been
supporting chess have really strong
ties with chess as we talked about some
of them have been
really the key sponsors of super
tournaments
like grinca like tata steel others have
been
uh you know also supporting not as an
organ at an organizational level
but in terms of like funding for the
world championship and a lot of other
initiatives
here are some of the initiatives that
are being supported by this particular
event
and through initiatives that fide is
working on it year-round
they include chess in education as fide
is organizing seminars and support
for people to teach chess all around the
world in many communities
that just don't have a lot of
infrastructure to support chess
supplying boards instructors seminars
training for
all of those who are working in these
communities it's fantastic
this year we had the first fide online
olympiad for
people with disabilities there was a lot
of great buzz about that on social media
a lot of really fantastic chess players
playing in that event and i know that
the
winning brilliancy game got a lot of
attention there for that event
and finally the feed a chess veteran
support program
is a an incredible initiative being a
top chess player
is really really difficult financially
that's
one of the reasons that many of the
players in this event who are grand
masters who are great chess players like
joe laudier
have pursued a career in business
because it's much
more easy and stable to make a living
but through this event
working with these companies for the
corporate championship here
we are able to fund events like the
veterans support program where these
grand masters
who did so much in their career to
promote chess
and play chess brilliantly have funding
to help them
you know as they're now retired and they
may not have like benefits or retirement
to fall back on that's not something
that's given to a professional chess
player
and it can be a challenging situation
when a grandmaster is no longer
able to earn a living directly from
their play
and their coaching that's that's true
and it is a very individual sport but
fide is doing great job with these
initiatives to try to support some of
the
players who may not be able to earn a
stable living
and i think it's it's been great and we
hope to see
more donations come through for the
charities and that's what this event's
all about
it's of course a spot to win you know
trying to win a championship
and then be able to go to the world
championship
at the end of the year but of also to
raise awareness
to raise funds it's a great cause and
uh we do have a game up in front of us
right now it's the one between yonder
palmishi
and he's playing a women's international
master so far so good i think that 1282
rating
that's not accurate i don't think that
black has the ring just based on the set
up here this is
a nice setup for black with the pawn
chains
aiming at the d5 square you got the pawn
triangle it's very solid but it's often
difficult to come up with a concrete
plan
whereas white can play e4 in the very
near future
open up that bishop on c1 and with the
bishop pair
you want open space for those bishops
absolutely and it makes me think a
little bit of the setup that magnus
carlsen selected against anton korabov
in the prior round not exactly the same
at all but
a very solid setup for black who has
given up
that bishop pair it seems like maybe jan
has a little bit more to work with here
but of course he doesn't have any
significant
opening advantage and he's going to have
to make something happen
from this point forward one thing maybe
in his favor is at this point his
opponent is thinking and has used a
minute more than him
and doesn't seem to really know how to
continue at this point
where they've just left the opening and
no pawns have been traded so you can
think of a capture on c4 or playing
one of these pawn moves for blacks c5 e5
but they're going to be consequences
with every single move made
and queen e7 ultimate choice let's not
change the pawn structure i like the
triangle i'm very solid
and if e4 happens i'm ready to meet that
we'll have some trades
that gives black pieces more flexibility
as well and
sam i do want to go to the game with
magnus carlsen
uh just to see how the opening is gone
and well he's clearly
hey and i see some donations on screen
though thank you so much to andre
maslock
for the 10 donation all this goes to
charity it is
a really appreciative these great
initiatives that fide is organized so
thank you so much for that and as you
can see on the bar
beneath the games there that's how much
has been raised thus far we appreciate
every single cent
um but this magnus game here you see
queen trade being offered
and black rated 2 300 plus
strong player what do you make of this
situation sam
well it looks to me like black is
playing very reasonably against the
world champion
in round one we saw magnus playing very
aggressively with the king's gambit
but not so much in this particular round
the computer's indicating a small
advantage
here for white that's got to be about as
small an advantage as you can get with
the white pieces i don't know i would
certainly be inclined to just go equal
at this point in the game
of course magnus carlsen is maybe the
greatest player
of all time in terms of making a small
advantage into something
very very serious but so far black is
playing great
and it's by no means a lock here that
magnus is going to be able to win this
game he's going to have to really
produce
something interesting from here on to
kind of convert
whatever he hopes to get out of this
position i don't think that we really
know right away
what he's going to be able to work with
this looks very very symmetrical and
equal
he wanted a neutral position where
there's no opening theory that he could
just outplay his opponent from and what
white is going to do
very likely is push the pawn of g4
probably park the king on f2 it depends
on what happens
and then start pushing these king side
pawns and you just make the claim that i
can quickly gain space
my pawns have more mobility than black's
pawns do and that's why f3 is
useful and the knight on f6 i say this
very frequently a knight is often
dominated by a pawn three squares away
this pawn takes away e4 it takes away g4
so what's your knight doing here it's
fine
it's solid but it doesn't actually have
anywhere forward to go
and on the other hand white can use the
f3 pawn to help push through g4 so if
magnus
he has ideas he's also now up quite a
bit of time
and his camera is crystal clear oh his
camera's great i'm looking at that and
like wow
i think that many of us remember um you
know fantastic
uh banter blitz videos that magnus has
done where his camera
had some glitchiness i think some of us
have seen some of those videos but
obviously right now his camera's looking
stellar
it really is and well we know we like to
talk about
magnus and his games so far uh not too
many moves been played black thinking
here let's go to the game between anish
giri
uh and part of that option match up
where we were looking at the pairings
before the round
on board four optivar is just completely
outraged on that board so they're hoping
that a niche
can come through for them against
rossetti volga a very strong team
in their own right board four for volga
is
2100 plus and they have a grandmaster on
board one
this is a serious contender absolutely
uh really exciting match-up very
competitive
uh tough opponent for a niche and a
niche really needs to win as you're
saying because
they're very outraged on board four
it would be very surprising if they're
able to get a half point
or a full point in that particular board
so they're going to need to outscore
them in just three boards
this h5 is very interesting and of
course immediately recalls the anisimov
game
we were looking at the advance h5
and yes it looks like anisha is really
generating
some very inconvenient pressure against
the white king he has more space
this is an example of a position where
the isolated pawn is conferring
all of the kind of extra dynamic
opportunities that you really want when
you're taking on an isolated pawn
and you can just see from anisha's
previous move
that knight e5 was played and that
somebody say wait that pawn b7 can't you
capture that
well you take on b7 in comes this knight
to c4
hitting the bishop hitting e3 hitting b2
rook b8 next coming down the b
file white's position is specifically
collapsing b5
no bishop b5 is controlled by the knight
on d4 i thought we might have a chance
to trap the queen i'm not sure about
that oh yeah it's very close actually
you know in the near future rook to b8
queen's only one safe scoring if you can
make bishop b5
or rook e or b6 one of those moves so
close to trapping the queen
it may in fact be possible you're right
sam
but he won rook c3 uh did
the ocean and knight c4 bishop c1 so
it's kind of a sad
state of affairs for white here and
anish keeps pushing through like
b5 b4 let's break open the position and
your bishop went back to c1 and your
pieces are awkward
it definitely feels to me like i want to
try
an attack on the king side for a niche
but he's really sealing up the the queen
side over here
i don't know if he's going to transition
to a king side attack at some point with
that queen
buried on a2 it really feels like the
time
to make these kind of attacking
opportunities work
um and maybe he's headed there it's just
that he's sealing up the
uh white queen side and he's going to
create an initiative over on the king
side at some point
and look at this move e4 just that's
walking
into black's plans i get it the bish1c1
didn't look good
but after takes takes now e4 is
already capturable it seems this g4
square is black's for the taking
so i think white's king is way too
exposed and you don't have any active
play of your own
i'm kind of surprised he hasn't taken on
e4 yet there he goes
because even though there seemed like
there might be some other good options
it was hard to believe that there was
necessarily a definitively better option
than taking on e4 because that was so
good
but wow anisha's pieces just look so
great in this position
and he's got an extra pawn uh to be
entirely honest i'm not sure where the
pawn was dropped
uh but at some point oh it was only four
yeah
it was just e4 that was just a hanging
pot it was just a hanging pot that
wasn't a trade
just took that that was free 99 and well
this bishop on g4
is now attacking the rook the knight
behind it and that knight could even
come back to e4 at some point soon
white essentially relying on hey can my
rooks attack you and is my queen through
your knight
also helping out the answer is no black
is safe and sound here and white's
position
is falling apart down one pawn and
looking like you're about to lose more
material
right aneesh is just making it look
you know almost simple against a
grandmaster
you know it's never simple but he's
certainly making it look that way as
he's just
dominating the board really really you
know
incredible play super instructive and
he's picked up an exchange it's you know
looks that easy when it's a niche kyrie
doing it but
it's not that easy a lot of what happens
in chess is behind the scenes in the
players heads they're calculating all
these lines
but anish just beat a strong grandmaster
he didn't win yet the game is not over
but
he is going to win if we're being honest
and he's doing it
just quickly he's mopping up the
material
and now his kick is safe he's up a rook
for just
a knight and the white king is still in
worse shape this knight comes into e3
this rook on the c file could get in at
some point soon
so i think that this is a win in the
battle for
team optivar i think any time you
see a grand master get a win that
quote looks easy and obviously i'm the
one who's saying that um
what you should do is really take a
close look at that play because it's
probably some of the most instructive
play you're going to get to
to you know sample uh so like when a
niche
makes it look easy here that's a really
good cue that there were probably a lot
of
small moves that really deserve
close attention right that he managed to
create
the opportunities uh you know to put
this pressure on his opponent where his
opponent felt so suffocated
as a really really strong player that he
just had no choice but e4
um in that position just incredible play
from a niche
yes he's gonna win this game i say that
with a high degree of confidence
let's go to the match up between
radissal voitacek
and lavon bragazi we saw that crazy
queen sacrifice
in the first round by bergazzi now he
has the white pieces against super
grandmaster voy tajik
one of the best players in the world
representing uh wasco from poland
and he is uh these number two in poland
was number one for a long time
until jan christoph duda skyrocketed in
the rankings and look at this position
sam
what happens on knight takes a6 knight
takes
something desperado style possible in
this position like bishop takes g2
yeah i'm just going to show off their
pawn a6 rook takes c6 at sam's point
they kind of steal that pawn
and so sam teaching everybody about the
desperado can i just go take on g2
you took my pawn i take yours it seems
like with the help of the
engine here there's probably some kind
of rook c7 check in your rook
if it slides at d7 to defend which is
how you want to defend
once i end up trading here my knight can
come to c5 so i
don't take your bishop just like you
didn't take my knight and i guess i
can attack your rook and your bishop at
the same time you can't protect both
right so what is the antidote tonight
takes a6 in the
in the position because i don't know
well
i just played it was played so we'll
find out what what totic has in store
because that
looks like you drop a pawn and i would
say that
maybe you start with rook d1 check
that comes to mind is they trying to
trade off
rooks but it's possible as well that
voitach underestimated
this possibility i mean i see the eval
bar telling me it's equal and i'm like i
think i have a pawn i don't understand
so obviously there's something in the
position
that neither of us are picking up on at
the moment but
some way must exist now the big question
of course is does radoslav see it
um it's his clock that's running
fortunately for us
i think that there's a change with rook
to d1 check because if you swap off a
pair of rooks
here and the king comes to h2 you
actually just see that the evo r is
going crazy
and there's a move like bishop d5 just
like i didn't
take that bishop ones on g2 you can play
bishop d5
and you say wait that's not that big a
deal give me a check but then when the
king
goes out here this rook is under attack
needing the knight's defense the knight
can't move
the bishop protects the pawn and if you
move the rook away say you take on g7
you lose your knight in a6 so black is
able to
steal that so and it's the rook exchange
that's white's problem here because
without the rook exchange then the rook
would be defended on c7
and you wouldn't be overextended um so
did rookie one check happen in the game
no i'm i'm just making the game
i haven't looked at the game and even
here bishop takes a4 bishop d5
looks pretty good to win back your pawn
so to return to the game
as we went through all this announces no
rookie one check did happen king h2
was played so very smart play by
bergazzi understanding that i can't
swap on d1 i need my opponent to swap on
c1
and then after the trade there as
mentioned the bishop can sacrifice
itself on a4
or play bishop to d5 once the rooks get
traded and in which case
the knight will have to move and black
will regain the pawn
very very instructive stuff and of
course it's very
easy to probably look at this game after
the fact and
it's likely to be a draw of course many
things can still happen
but it does look like accurate play is
kind of
resolving the pressure here for the
black player
and to think oh that wasn't you know too
interesting and of course
there's all these little tactics and in
this case we're seeing them on the board
with knight takes a6 which is really
interesting and accurate responses from
voitacek but in many cases it might not
actually be on the board but it's still
being calculated
by both players and bishop takes g2
instead of these other lines that are
mentioned with bishop takes a4 bishop d5
and this is much more dynamic
and maybe voitachick is actually
thinking that he's trying to press and
to win this
position potentially by going for
what looks to be a sharper line although
the computer's not really a big fan
of this particular line yeah i think
that black could be in some trouble if
you're not careful in rook c7
the rook trade is offered and white gets
an outside passport by the way magnus
and anish have both won their games
madness winning that very quickly
considering it was a pretty neutral
position
and we have an endgame now sam where
there could be the presence of an
outside past pawn black saying if you
take my bishop
i take your knight and well i'm going to
win your pawns here so that's
off the table are we desperadoing
further with knight takes e6 i was
about to say i was about to say can we
take on e6
because this bishop is still under
attack so you take the knight
the bishop falls and well that seems to
win a pawn for white right there
he didn't go for it and i wonder if
maybe uh
maybe there was a concern that after
like bishop d5
your pawns are stuck on light squares
maybe they fall and maybe it's the b
pawn that is the most dangerous part on
the board in fact definitely the b pawn
is the most dangerous pawn on the board
it's just not clear if that's enough to
win the game or even to confer an
advantage
but i'm definitely picking the b pawn
over any other pawn that white has
or black has in the position and it's
easy to stop calculation early
oh desperado that looks bad because
white's still a pawn but actually as we
keep going here
the pawn a4 is a weakness and can be
easily taken
and knights are notoriously bad at
defending pawns on other side of the
board so
we saw b4 bishop c6 played an a5
but wait a second the black king isn't
this king just
coming over here to mop up these pawns
it is certainly feeling like voitachik
is
getting very very serious winning
chances
very difficult for bragazza to play at
this point
i love active king in the end game it's
just like one of my absolute
favorite themes in chess the king is you
know it's been so much time
trying to hide away the whole point of
the game is to uh
checkmates your opponent's king but when
you're in the end game
all of a sudden the white king on h2
which felt
safe a moment ago now feels inactive and
that black king on d5
is feeling like an absolute hero right
here of course
a lot is being traded maybe this is
still drawable but certainly black with
that king on d5
is the player who's pressing very
interesting of course
voitacek slowing down after pawn to a6
trying to figure out how he can generate
the maximum winning chances
in this position do you take on a6 when
more pieces get traded or do you allow
the pawn to remain
as a very kind of scary past pawn
but maybe also a weakness v6 is
really tempting where does that knight
even go it's limited
and after b6 if the knight goes back to
say b3
already this king can come to c4 and
then even try to win this a6 pawn
as well after that so i think that
voitaccik has the upper hand right now
and he takes on a6 and even here
he's better because this pawn is going
to fall very shortly the good thing for
the knight
is the pawns remaining on the same side
of the board so you may lose your
outside pawn
but with the pawns on the same side of
the board the knight is better at
controlling those
and that knight is jumping back very
very quickly to try and get counter play
pick off a pawn immediately attacking
the e6 pawn
is bishop d5 the right way to defend
bishop d5 would allow 98
among other potential concerns
bishop d7 instead to make sure that
you're controlling the e8
and e6 squares and b4 should fall black
should be up a pawn is it enough to win
uncertain also can you just
trap that knight that's that feels
a very serious concern and that's the
problem with knights i mean bishops
control them very well
king can come to b5 now and the knight
will
run away to potentially c5 but this b4
pawn is falling so
after bishop c8 it just went to equal
and then back up so knight
to c7 is the wrong move even though i
understand why bergat would play to
repeat trying to get to e8 so bishop c
was the mistake and i don't think that
whitachi will necessarily repeat it
after 1986. so what's the better move
here that
secures an advantage
could you make like a pawn move somehow
you have an extra pawn on the kings
there if we cut the board
on the this half here right black has an
extra pawn so
he does move his bishop back here he
looks like he's about to win this pawn
so you figure it away out
but at some point you will probably have
to push your pawns if you expect to win
this game
[Music]
so some advantage with the extra pawn
here obviously a serious advantage
enough to win unclear
it's of course as you mentioned nice
that the the knight is defending
all on one side right if you have an
extra pawn and that pawn is over on the
queen side
it's just very easily decisive with all
the pawns on one side the knight is just
much much better equipped to defend
against the bishop
and to try to construct a defense on the
color complex that the bishop does not
control
right and the pawn on h7 matches the
color of the bishop in the corner
so that gives good winning chances for
erotic long term i mention this
all the time h1 queenie square light
square bishop
it's a match so if this knight thought
about sacrificing itself for some pawns
probably won't work out right black's
pawns are doing a great job controlling
the knight at the at this particular
moment um
that pawn is headed knight g6 can you
play g6
oh oh my gosh because we take h6 happens
and
white wins the game it just looks fun i
don't know if it's
but i love moves like that it's played
yeah
h6 is going to be played right because
if you allow
h6 and then knight f uh f8 then white
could potentially be winning so
do you need to go h6 immediately right
here
to prevent that pawn from going forward
but then could the knight go to h8 and
f7 uh gosh
but i guess what black is going bishop
d7 uh
and e8 in a hurry to attack the pawn
right so i think
h6 is necessary the king runs back
so that's evidently sufficient yes
because the h6
king d6 knight f8 king e7 you do win
this pawn
but your knight is stuck so the king
comes to f7 and
i mean i'm going to trap your knight
soon especially if i get my bishop
around
the knights caught wow beautiful
beautiful idea
um just more instructive ideas regarding
the active king and the
important role that the king plays in
the end game here and
that's why bergashi of his nike seven
only about a minute per player of course
for attacking under that minute
he's up a pawn but this knight is such a
thorn it's going all around but
sam you mentioned this earlier we keep
talking that knight could possibly get
trapped
it could get trapped it could also
create some serious problems after
knight g8
attacking the f6 pawn and then knight to
f6
uh so this is this is very double edged
and black is up a pawn and now the
engine is saying that uh
white is actually better which is just
incredible
um rasheed nejmed dinov once said
that in blitz knights are better than
bishops and i think we're feeling that
here a little bit in this time scramble
we certainly are the pawn now cemented
on h7 the bishop cannot help
bishop e4 knight f6 you cannot push the
pawn to f4
because the knight would be hitting the
bishop so you would drop your bishop on
the square and look at vitac
down to 17 seconds he's trying to figure
this out he probably has to bring his
king
but now after knight f6 takes h7 g5 is a
safe square
he does bring the king back knight comes
back he does do the right thing
but sam in a blitz scramble this could
go badly
right i mean i think that everything
should be contained by voitacic but with
so little time
this is incredibly difficult of course
as the king approaches you feel
much much safer because you're defending
on a very very narrow front
and it is hard to see you know how white
can kind of force the pawn through the
pawn
has gone to h7 king has gone to g7 but
how do you get that pawn to h8
there probably really isn't a way yeah
he took it
okay that immediately basically agrees
the draw
friends good news now for uh black that
the pawns
are stuck on light squares your bishop
can come defend
if these pawns were stuck on dark
squares then the knight and the king
could team up
but right now the bishop can always come
to e4 or c8 depending on
what white's move is and seems like it's
going to be a whole but a nice game
by brigadzi who you know he won knight
takes a6 earlier
then he was in a bit of trouble he
worked his way out of it and he kept a
bit ahead in the clock
and i think that's really what's leading
him to this result
and of course brigadzi is outraged
against voitacek voitacic a 2700 player
super super strong
and bragaze is a hero for his team here
right they're one of the strongest teams
uh in the whole corporate championship
here
and him getting this draw against voy
tachik
is huge because he's not a grand master
international master obviously is a
huge skill as he's just demonstrated but
you know he's playing consistently
against grandmasters and he needs to
perform like he just did right now and
that's exactly
the kind of play and result that his
team is so excited to see from
him yes and well that's a big draw from
bergatzi
still more games underway oh actually i
was just clicking on this game and it
ends
and that's a loss for team optivar
and that's not good news for a nishkiri
and ko
because david pardo simon he loses with
the black pieces
that is checkmate on the board and that
means
optiver could be in some trouble uh
absolutely they are going to really
depend
on the final result i guess on board
three if we can pull that up uh board
two here
between karave and uh javier
alcarez in this position so alcarez has
white
um so anishkeri one
probably they're going to lose on board
four we don't actually know the result
of that uh
game but okay it's already in it's uh
1-0
for olga there so they really really
really need
the win here from the white pieces to be
able to level the score
and the computer is not loving white's
position
black has a lot of control over the dark
squares like has the bishop pair
black really feels like there might be
some chances to create
some very very serious pressure against
the opponent's king in this position
although are you looking to play here uh
if you're if you're black in this
position robert well i was going to say
that black is down a pawn
so the engine may see that composition
through but a human player is looking
wait a sec i'm down a pawn how do i
potentially win that back
and if i can't win that back how do i go
for some kind of checkmate
i'm looking at a bishop f4 in the near
future maybe a queen of four use those
dark squares that you mentioned
but maybe white will just put this rook
on c6 and say i'm trading off your
attacker please take me
give me a pass pawn here i feel like
white has a lot of play
right and i mentioned a moment ago that
like had the bishop pair
and that's no longer true of course
white managed to exchange that off which
seemed to make a lot of sense
i'm a benoni player so i love control
over the dark squares
uh but there are a lot of pieces missing
um
even a great mental new player and uh
proficient with the control of the dark
squares like mikhail tal i think really
might struggle to generate something
here
and e5 oh boy leveraging pressure
okay along the sixth rank in comes that
queen as you mentioned i would even
consider e6 to go after the
black king but taking on d6 is the
choice and if rook c1 there's pawn d7
this is an amazing tactical sequence
where you threaten to promote your pawn
while taking a rook
and it looks like black is there first
but you have this cool
move d7 you want to push your past pawns
here it comes with force and
rook d it's not the move you want to
play when you've just given up your
second pawn
nothing about the trajectory of the last
several moves is something that team
optivar wants to see
this is very very unfortunate great play
by
white the engine was definitely liking
the black position
and every move since has really kind of
converted the position a little more
uh in white's favor as white has
exchanged off
the light squared bishop has broken
through with e5
has captured on dc oh it works hanging
on and
there goes optimus
with the white pieces and they're going
to tie this matching seams
that is that is so difficult for
anisha's team we can see anish is glued
to the screen here we've got his camera
up we aren't able to get
access to his uh teammate's camera at
the moment but you can see he's glued to
the screen in this
this unfortunately is a tied match as
you say
it's going to be very difficult for
optivar to make it through to the finals
on sunday after
tying this match early in the third
round today with three more matches to
go tomorrow but i think
still with five and a half there's a
shot if they win
all matches from here on out and they
get really good tie breaks they have a
shot but it's going to be very very
difficult
you get very few missteps at this point
aneesh played
fantastically for his team but they were
in a very very difficult spot
in all of their matches outside of
anisha's board
wow i mean seriously what a turn of
events there if we just go back
a few moves even uh before that e5 push
was played by
white it looked very complicated here
the dark square control for black the
extra pawn for white
and then this move rook c8 e5
quickly it's turning in white's favor
it's not just one extra pawn it's the
second there's a pin on the sixth rank
so rook fc it's such a natural move but
as you can see by the
bar the engine bar not totally approved
they're
likely with something better maybe it
was queen f4 or bishop f4
just keeping the position a little more
solid queen of four makes a lot of sense
now
you walk out of the pin your queen can
come into g3 perhaps your rook still can
go to c8 next move
and unfortunately for a caravan here
walked right into it and then e takes d6
again great shot because rook c1 d7
wins the game as your rook needs to stay
in front of the pawn
and then you can just take here
the liquidation certainly winning for
white brook c6 to c8 for example right
and potentially black did see this idea
of going for rook c1 of e5 and still
going for rook c1 and may have missed
this d7 idea i don't know if it would
have worked
even without b7 being possible but that
was a very nice counterpoint
from white to really turn the game in
white's favor
you know we can easily focus on the rook
drop on b3
but at that point everything was so much
in white's direction
uh and black needed to win the game not
just to draw the game
i think that it's a very very well
earned uh match victory
from uh from the russian team right and
that eventual rook
dropping b3 as you said it was already a
tough position no time really remaining
for black
so it's a nice win for optivar the even
the match 2-2 and there's still a lot to
play for as you said five and a half out
of six
with relatively few teams in the pools
that
will give you a chance especially if you
know you keep winning and then you place
i need to correct myself i said five and
a half out of six might do it but
i think they lost the match they didn't
draw it so
unfortunately they were hoping to have a
chance at five and a half out of six
but they could only get to five out of
six now so it's unlikely that anisha's
team will be able to make it through
optiva probably
almost mathematically impossible for
them to get to the final i think when
you lose a match
in this format with as many teams as
there are i
don't think five is going to be enough
points out of six particular
rounds to make it through maybe i'm
wrong and i'm
basing that on prior team tournaments
and this is
really really a challenging team
tournament but i suspect you're gonna
need five and a half
okay yeah i mean that makes sense and uh
just a reminder that's
swiss pairing so you only get to play
the teams once if you've already played
so if you're
you draw a match you don't have another
chance to beat them
and well let's look at some of the
scores from the round we saw kindred win
they won three to one magnus carlson led
the way on board one
he of course outraged his opponent
greatly and uh that was a nice win
for the kindred team and anish giri we
saw that one just finished optivier ties
against rosetti volga
2-2 anish wins on board one they have a
win on board two and there's an upset on
board three because david pardo simon
was the high rated player
but with the black pieces against such a
strong opponent like
mikhail rhoden just uh one of those days
right i have to you could you you caught
it again i
had the players reversed in this
particular match so the white one was
the
two two tie that you were pointing out
in my head i had
uh the result backward for optivar in
this final game
of course it was the uh the upset
on board three that led to the match tie
so very very dramatic finish here and
not de bear's match
yeah there's so many different matchups
going on uh we're doing our best
everybody please forgive us if we're not
focusing on your team or
uh you know if you're a fan favorite or
if you are
actually working a company we apologize
just countless teams going on and we're
trying to do the best we can and
uh well jana pamashi is doing the best
he can because he won again
for his team uh from spare and they beat
the bank of russia so it was a russian
clash
and janupam she leads the way for his
team
and obviously jan's a huge player
there's so many good players
competing for russian companies in this
event yan being
one that's certainly going to get
attention uh close attention throughout
this particular event
also our team we have just many many
great representatives of russian
companies competing in this event
well speaking of russian companies
aeroflot taking part they
host the famous aeroflot open which has
been a mainstay of the world of chess
for so long they have different groups
and they won 4-0 led by vladislav temiev
on the top board
so they continue to be a real
force on the chess scene in positive
ways and
of course many other matchups took place
you can go to the chess.com events page
to
look at standings of course on chest ash
results there will be standings there
as well and just so much to keep track
of
and there's still another day tomorrow
but also
more matches later because we have the
western pool starting at 5 30 p.m
pacific time
that's tonight and there will be more
matches tomorrow
finishing out stage one and the top team
from each group
will end up playing on sunday so here we
see the standings
and we see the leaders i don't know if
there are any surprises
sam but the czech national bank there
before the round was at least
up top with concentrics and others and
well three rounds are in the books so
some of these stainings will get updated
as day goes on
games are just finishing sam i don't
know what to make of everything we've
seen
any uh big thoughts you know i really
didn't expect
the level of matchups that we saw today
to be entirely honest
you know this was just the first three
rounds tomorrow we have three more
rounds
and i really thought that there would
maybe be more mismatches
on individual boards and among the
different companies that we're playing
because you have you know players like
magnus cross and amish gary artemiev
and there have been some mismatches but
consistently they've had really really
tough
opponents the matches have consistently
in this last round and even in round two
been very hard fought
very difficult to get a 4-0 score
and there's just going to be a ton to
play for tomorrow
where in this 10-2 time control with
four boards
there's going to be more of these
examples like this
optivar verse rossetti volga match where
there's one game left and it's just a
time scramble
and the entire team's fate really
depends on that one game and what
happens right there
and there's a lot of chess talent at
these companies not just the magnus
carlsen and each gears of the world but
as you can tell
in this optimal match they had
international masters that work at these
companies so
chess is very popular it's played all
around the globe we'd love to see it
this has
been a great start to this international
competition for the
world championship world corporate
championship that's such a
an honor to take part in it and to win a
title
and much more is to come we want to
remind everybody one last time for now
that this is also a call to action
raising money for charity fidei has done
a great job leading the way here
and there are some fantastic initiatives
where everyone can take part
and give if able so thank you on behalf
of myself
sam it's been a pleasure commenting with
this with you
and i guess up next uh there's gonna be
pogchamps before more
from this feed a online
world corporate chess championship so
much chess to enjoy these days
uh thank you robert this has been an
absolute pleasure to enjoy this chess
with you
[Music]
you